-Our next guest is
a talented comedian
who has written a new book
called "The History of Stand-Up:
From Mark Twain
to Dave Chappelle,"
which is available now.
Please welcome Wayne Federman!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Chuckling ] Wow! Wow!
-Yes.
-This is --
This is unbelievable.
Thank you so much for coming on.
Wayne, it's great to see you.
How have you -- How have you --
How have you been?
How is everything going?
-Well, it's actually
going pretty well.
I -- You know, everyone does
their own self-care
during the pandemic.
I saw Anna --
she did her exercising.
And, of course,
I am doing, you know --
I microdose --
Claritin is my system.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, microdosing Claritin.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's -- That's what I do.
But it's been really fun.
It's been really fun.
Something crazy happened
during the pandemic to me.
I had my identity stolen.
-No! Wayne, that's t--
-Yeah, yeah.
-That's terrible.
-Yeah, so -- No, no, it actually
was one of the best things
that happened to me,
'cause I go through life,
and I wonder, you know,
"Do I matter?
Does any of this count?"
[ Laughter ]
"Do I make a difference?"
Then one day I wake up,
and someone's like,
"Hey, I want to be you, Wayne."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Somebody wants to be me.
[ Scattered cheers ]
Yeah.
-Wow, that's -- that's amazing.
Now, I know
you and Anna Kendrick
worked on a project together.
-Yes, we did.
-And I was gonna bring it up.
-What --
-It was on Quibi.
It was called "Dummy."
She played a woman
that could talk
to her boyfriend's sex doll.
It was incredible.
And I, of course --
I think you can tell --
I played the sex-doll repairman
in that.
[ Laughter ]
And what happens is
the show didn't get canceled --
the whole platform got canceled,
the whole network.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, that's a first.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
But, apparently,
Anna's been able to bounce back
pretty nicely, so, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-I was looking
at your -- your credits online.
-Yeah.
-And, you know, you have
over 100 credits in movies.
What do you get recognized
the most for?
-Well, probably, maybe
"Curb Your Enthusiasm,"
but, also, there's this thing
where I am in,
like, a lot of movies,
but just in one scene.
Like, in "Legally Blonde,"
I'm part of the Harvard Board
that lets Elle Woods
into college.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Pivotal part of that movie,
very important.
-I like that.
-I'm also the blind guy
in "Step Brothers."
I'm in one scene in a movie,
and then gone.
You never see me again.
I call it the
"Federman-and-out."
I'm just in, and then...
[ Laughter ]
I think it's --
-The Federman-and-out.
-I think it's 'cause my acting
is so precise and effervescent
that it just would ruin
the narrative arc
of any movie, so...
-[ Laughs ] That's interesting.
I want to talk about your book,
"The History of Stand-Up."
-Yes.
-I'm really excited
about this, buddy.
It is a fantastic book.
It's a great read.
It's funny.
But I love that you did this!
I'm actually, like, kind of
jealous that you did this,
that I don't have the brain
to do this,
but 'cause...
-Aww.
-...I love every story in here.
-Thank you so --
Thank you so much.
I -- It was a great thrill
to put it together.
I've -- Again,
I've only done stand-up,
so this is my first time
on this show as an author.
So I'll just start right here.
Chapter 1.
"Who was the first comedian?"
-No, no, no.
Wayne, Wayne, Wayne, Wayne.
Wayne, Wayne, Wayne.
That's not how this -- You don't
read the book on the show.
That's not how we do it.
-Oh, I see.
No, no, I just talk to you --
We talk about the book.
-You want me to go
to the ending?
Do you want me
to tell you how it ends?
-No, I -- No.
No, thank you.
I appreciate it.
No spoilers.
It's the evolution
of stand-up comedy.
-I know. And there
was people doing stand-up
before the term "stand-up"
even existed.
So it was like --
it's really interesting.
Like, Mark Twain, and there's
a guy called Artemus Ward.
And I go through every era --
Vaudeville, nightclubs.
-Now, Artemus -- I never
even knew anything about that.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, the term "stand-up"
came about in 1947,
but, like,
Bob Hope was doing stand-up,
you know, in the '30s
and in the '20s and stuff.
So it's really interesting.
So we cover
all of the whole thing,
right up through,
you know, the comedy boom,
when you joined in, in the '90s.
When did --
When did you start, Jimmy?
-Yeah, it probably was '90s.
Yeah '90-- probably --
-In the '90s, yeah.
So you were at, probably,
the comedy club.
And so,
we cover right the whole --
right through the pandemic.
We do the greats, you know,
Pryor and Moms Mabley.
And then we do some, like,
Wally Boag and Elsie Janis,
some people
you might not have known about.
And, you know, I'm always --
a lot of it --
there's a lot of George Carlin
in this.
It's just fun to think about,
like, Carlin as a young comic,
and then he became this legend,
and, like, this story
keeps going over and over again.
And now there's new,
incredible comedians.
So, that's what the story is.
-Wayne, before I give you the --
our outro here,
I just want to tell you that,
actually,
you're one
of my favorite comedians
that I've ever seen, ever.
And I'm just
so honored and lucky
that I got to hang out with you
and -- and work with you.
I really am a giant fan
of yours, dude.
-Ah, thank you.
Ah. That's incredible.
I loved the way the audience
burst into spontaneous applause
when you said that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was -- That felt good.
-Yeah, I don't know
what they were waiting for.
-I --
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, no, no,
this has been a blast.
And the one thing I really wish
I was in studio for, Jimmy,
is just the very, you know,
the fact that when you throw,
like, the host throws
to the commercial...
-Yeah.
-...and then leans over
to the guest and does, like,
a little intimate conversation,
and the audience doesn't know --
no one knows
what they're saying.
I wish we could have done that,
but we can't.
But, anyway, thanks again
for having me on the show.
I really appreciate it.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-I-I -- We can -- We can --
I think we can try
to make something work out.
Wayne Federman, everybody.